good afternoon council um thank you for
being with us uh this afternoon so to
kick off i'd like to invite councillor
dixon to say some words
thank you
chairman it's very close to the uh the
start of a new year
and possibly the start of a new epoch
for south warwickshire
so i came across something which is
entitled the gate of the year
i'll take that off it's a lot easier
i said to the man who stood at the gate
of the year
give me a light that i may tread safely
into the unknown
and he replied
go out into the darkness and put your
hand into the hand of your god
that shall be to you better
than the light and safer than a known
way
so i went forth
under finding the hand of my god trod
gladly into the night
and he led me towards the hills and to
the breaking of the day
in the lone east
thank you chairman
thank you councillor dixon um item one
on the agenda apologies for absence um
i'd like to invite the head of paid
service to report the list of apologies
for absence chairman thank you we have
apologies this afternoon from
councillors adam wallcock cargill crump
harris and henshaw seraphin
thank you and that councilor pemberton
will be late for the meeting thank you
thank you very much uh item number two
disclosures of interest i invite any
members to make their declarations of
interest to the meeting
nope
item number three um just to confirm the
minute to the meeting held on the 18th
of october and i'll seek a proposal
please
uh councillor fielding and a seconder
councillor dixon thank you so much is it
all in agreement
yep thank you
um
item number four so i'm not gonna have
any announcements today to help us whiz
through the meeting but i would like to
invite the leader followed by the chief
executive to make their announcements
thank you chair some very brief
announcements
uh i visited the very light rail
demonstrator of the iron bridge to
discover it was actually built in long
marston
and the headquarters of the organization
that built it
was in stratford-on-even which i thought
was quite interesting
i had a meeting at wellsborne between
stratford district council
and the university of warwick
it was a meeting that lasted half a day
and it was information sharing about
both the council
and about the wells born campus
i would also just like to say that we
now have fairly regular meetings with
the university warwick to discuss
progress on the wellsborne campus thank
you
thank you chairman two items from myself
firstly if i could please remind
councillors later this week we have the
um personal safety and conflict
resolution training
that's being held on thursday evening
has been run by the local government
association you should have all received
an invitation from washington county
council directly for that training if
you haven't could you please let
caroline or somebody in committee
services know
and the second announcement for myself
contrary to my email last week which
suggested that we'll be considering the
adoption of the revised enforcement
policy and business charter at this
meeting there's an urgent item it won't
be considered this afternoon it will be
considered at the february meeting the
council thank
you
thank you and just quickly to add
there's no need to stand up in today's
meeting we'll stay seated um
and then also just one two and four
members that the order of the agenda
will change bringing forward
the urgent business item on virtual
meetings and that's the green paper
great so uh moving on to item number
five uh we've got one question from mr
lee rhodes um
so please uh mr rhodes uh could you
stand and read out your question thank
you
good afternoon
my question was addressed to councillor
pebble
pemberton peggy podd um i would like to
ask if the liberal democratic members of
this council have a opposed or b
sought to feed back to the government
via this council
concerns over the government's plans to
change planning laws i have looked at
the minutes online of recent meetings
and cannot see any evidence of such
opposition provided
thank you mr rhodes have you seen the
responses on the yellow piece of paper
yeah thank you do you have a
supplementary question thank you
thank you
um i've corresponded with local mp
nadeem zahawi who tells me that the
government is bringing forward a range
of reforms to ensure that our planning
system is fit for the 21st century
indeed as planning is one of the key
functions of this council can i ask if
the council intends any consultation
with the public or we'll express any
concerns to either the minister for
local government or our own mp on this
matter thank you
thank you like to invite councillor
jefferson to respond
thank you for your question i will ask
councillor pemberton to respond directly
to you
all right thank you mr rhodes
um item six on the
sorry
okay item six on the
sorry counselor junaid
just one one point uh last time when the
consultation on the planning reforms
came it came in august during the during
the holiday season um could we be kept
up to date because we don't want uh an
announcement of this importance to come
to us during the holiday season so if
there is to be any consultation then uh
we need to that we need to um be aware
in good time
great thank you so much um item six um
some minutes 351 joint organizational
change policy statement update i'd like
to invite councillor jefferson as leader
of the council to introduce this report
please
thank you chairman
i think the crooks of uh this is
contained in the second paragraph on
page 31.
um
the reality actually is
we have revised the recommendations
given the feedback we've had
from uh the unions
and i therefore propose that we accept
uh the recommendations to counsel
uh to replace the wording
with
uh to use section 113 of the local
government act 1972 jointly across the
organizations which allows a local
authority to enter into an agreement
with another authority to place its
offices at the disposal of the other
authority
subject to consultation with the staff
concerned
and to to approve the heads of paid
service at stratford-on-haven and
warwick district councils to enter into
a collective agreement with both sdc and
wcdc branches of unison to vary terms
and conditions of employment to
incorporate the use of section 113
agreements in employee contracts so i
propose that mr chairman thank you and
i'll look for a seconder
councillor shenzhen thank you so much
um are there any other members who'd
like to speak
on this one
nope um so i think that's an agreement
thank you so much
yep are we agreed
thank you
so item number seven minute 393 the
appointment of external auditors i'd
like to invite councillor foreman as the
vice chairman of the audits and
standards committee to introduce this
report
thank you chair
the meeting of the audit and standards
committee was held on the 15th of
november 2021
which the following item had been
considered and referred to council for
determination the appointment of
external auditors the report sets out
the proposals for appointing the
external auditor to the council for the
accounts for the five year period from
2023 to 2024
i propose
that the audit and standards committee
recommended to the council to accept the
public sector audit appointments
invitation
to opt into the sector-led opinion for
the appointment of external auditors to
principal local governments and police
bodies for five financial years from the
1st of april 2023
thank you now look for a seconder
council fielding thank you
would anyone else like to speak on this
point uh councillor kettle
uh thank you mr chairman i would just
add uh or like to comment that um a lot
of public sector audits have been
delayed considerably this year
uh under the um
problems caused by kovid
or lack of resourcing one or the other i
would recommend that when we do start
looking for next year's auditors that uh
mr buckland and his team
do ensure
that the auditors prepare to commit the
right level of resources to get the
audited accounts in front of this
council on a timely basis
um
when we do next year
great thank you are we in agreement to
uh pass this yep
agreed
thank you
uh so now looking at the cabinet from
the 6th of december we've got item
number eight minutes 418. the notice of
promotion was universal credit cuts uh
please my invites counselor barca
support portfolio holder for homes
health and wellbeing
to introduce this report please
um you'll find uh the report item eight
on a separate piece of paper and if you
want to refer to
the
what we discussed at the meeting
uh of cabinet on the ninth i think it
was
um that's page 11 and onwards
um the consideration was made um to this
notice of motion um as that had been
presented on the 18th of october
um we were informed that we're already
making every effort to support and work
with stakeholders and i would
um endorse that completely because
that's exactly what we do plus
um in talk in talking to officers
officers
working with the local government
association and other councils
are lobbying on this matter
um councillor peter geller addressed the
meeting of cabinet with some
wide-ranging
and interesting facts about
general
work and pensions issues
on top of just the universal credit
but the bottom line with this was that
cabinet decided on the basis of the
information we had before us and the
ability we have to lobby that this
motion was not something that we could
support therefore we rejected it and
that's our recommendation to council
thank you
thank you is there a second uh please
uh councillor jennings thank you uh
counselor together
thank you chair
so the 20 pounds universal credit uplift
represented a lifeline
often the only means by which families
did not get into debt and poverty in
this respect it has been a very good
benefit entitlement and the cut is just
a cruel move by this government
and we're rising energy costs and rises
in food prices the council on report
which was
circulated to councillors a couple of
weeks ago and was titled changes to
covet 19 financial support measures
stated that and i quote
many individuals and families will find
it increasingly difficult to make ends
meet
in our district we have
nearly 8 000 people claiming universal
credit
and that's only in august 2021 and
more than 4 000 of these claimants are
not in employment for any reason
which means that they won't benefit from
the chancellor taper rate so i am very
disappointed that the cabinet is
recommending this motion for rejection
the motion asks to look at the impact of
these changes on our services so it is
bizarre
that emotion holding the council to
account is rejected
secondly the motion asks the council to
write to the government and mps
outlining our very worrying data and
make a stand against the cuts
indeed several other councils have done
this while also lobbying the lga
once again the most vulnerable of our
residents are being let down by the
conservative leaders of this council and
i hope that the rest of the councillor
will oppose the cabinet's rejection
thank you
okay thank you so are we in agreement
with um item eight
no okay thank you so much i will now
have a
um a vote please for the um item eight
on the
um agenda
yeah chairman if those in favor of the
motion could please raise their cards we
will we'll do a account and then
we'll do those against the short one
so please raise your card if you're for
the
yeah so you're gonna
just clarify so the recommendation
that's been brought by the cabinet is
what we're voting on now so the
recommendation is presented by
councillor uh barca to reject the motion
all those in favor please if you could
please raise your cards but we can do
now thank you
thank you
um item nine minutes 419 the digital
strategy i'd like to invite council
jefferson to introduce this report
thank you chairman
um
there are some very straight ish issues
at the heart of this paper
the first is
that warwick district council and
stratfor district council have very
different approach quite different
approaches when it comes to dealing with
digital
the second key point is that neither
councils currently has an adopted
digital strategy
there are an awful lot of issues in
terms of uh operation of a significant
number of legacy line of business
applications that are outlined in table
two of the paper
it is also absolutely clear that the
digital strategy is vital
to actually the delivery of the benefits
we can get if we approve the merger
later so in that case i'm on the digital
strategy is in this document which
you've all seen
and i particularly like the bits that
say
what we are going to do
as i think those are excellent ways of
actually holding
officers to account for actually
delivery of the digital strategy
so without further ado uh the
recommendations to council are that the
deep draft digital strategy has is
accepted
a digital transformation program is
initiated to deliver the outcomes
identified in the digital strategy
and a governance structure is adopted
for the digital transformation program
uh i propose we accept those
recommendations
thank you i'm just going to look for a
second uh uh please a seconder
councillor barker council junit um just
to say that i
not only do i welcome the fact that uh
there is to be uh a review of the uh of
the digital and the comparison between
the two councils um that that
and could i also just say how oh perhaps
you can't hear me uh perhaps i could all
say how f i delighted i was that there
was a frankness
to the problems and there certainly are
problems but you know particularly with
stratford's um digital offering uh which
is in in the report and i shan't refer
further to it except that you know it is
difficult for some people to access um
in fact quite a number of people to
access uh the digital services of this
council but can i just
in
in comment just say could we
bear in mind no matter how improved that
the service is that there will always be
those people who can't refer to it who
can't use it and particularly we have to
it has to be hand in hand with improved
um
improved kind of broadband services
across the area include improved mobile
phone uh services across the area uh for
some people who have only a
mobile phone to access the services and
with poor service connection it is
extremely difficult and it probably will
remain extremely difficult even with an
improved offer so could i just ask that
that is really taken on board that there
will always be some people who will not
who will find it difficult to access the
service
thank you councillor infrastructure
uh thank you chair um i'm afraid
councillor julia dunet has already asked
the question i don't want to ask about
the
uh placing a priority on broadband to
the rural communities
thank you councillor kettle
over enthusiastic international
out that there will be a very full cost
focused on costs to make sure that dust
can be within
thank you are we in agreement to move
that agreed
great thank you
item 10 minute 420 the treasury
management strategy mid year review um
so i'd like to invite councillor harvey
a portfolio holder for resources
sorry to counsel junaid
could i just ask um there used to be
various meetings of advisory groups
particularly to local investment uh are
we carrying on with those advisory
groups and if so could you please let me
know when the next one is think thank
you yep later thank you
please invite councillor harvey
uh thank you mr chairman
uh at its meeting on 6th of december
2021 the cabinet considered a paper that
reviewed the management of the council's
treasury management function
as required by the relevant sipfer code
of practice
the seven areas addressed by the review
are set out in minute 420
on the basis of the cabinet's review
i ask that council accepts the
recommendations set out in that minute
notably
that the 2021-22
treasury management strategy mid-year
review
including the treasury activity detailed
at para 1.9 of the agenda report
be noted
thank you mr chairman
thank you and i'll seek a second please
council shenson
anything else doesn't look like it are
we in agreement
i agree thanks thank you
um so moving on to item
uh 11 the council of questions
uh so copies have been circulated you'll
find so we've got nine questions have
been received
and you've got them on a separate sheet
so everyone who asks questions we'll
have a chance now to ask a supplementary
question um but first of all to know
that council penton isn't here so if
there's any further ones for him we'll
do it in writing
later on so there's question one uh
counselor june ed do you have any
supplementary questions
um just the the sub my supplementary is
that um i do need to i would like to be
kept up to date on this i would like to
be reassured that this will be a
fundamental part of the local plan and i
would like to pro
that it would be good if accepted by the
chair of overview and scrutiny that
maybe we have an update through the
opium scrutiny at a later stage thank
you great thank you and uh for question
two council junet do you have anything
else
um yes my my question on this on the
supplementary is that um i'm
disappointed that it's taking so long uh
to make progress and uh i am concerned
about those people who because of the uh
retrospective this is not a
retrospective um you know uh review of
of um that open space development and
responsibility for i'm still getting
people who complain about the the fact
that they've been left out and they've
been left in a very difficult situation
uh with private um landowners etc so
again any thoughts on improving their
situation would be welcomed
thank you councillor parry
thank you councillor junaid and i do
share your concerns as well and i can
reassure you that certainly our planning
department are it is it is very much
something that's top of their list
plus i can also advise particularly in
my adjacent award that from a parish
council point of view has recently taken
over a very large area of public open
space
and that our policy around this has
enabled this to happen um and certainly
it is very much a an area of priority
for us and we will continue to do what
we can in the circumstances thank you
thank you um councillor rolf do you have
a supplementary question
no i don't thank you jeff
thank you
question five counselor jenny frazerly
do you have any supplementary questions
uh yes uh may i just have an assurance
that the district will be uh alert to
any government money that might come
forward
for
these particular uh toilets uh because
last time it was a shame that we
actually missed out on the previous
grant so
i just want to make sure that people are
alert to any money that might be voting
thank you thank you councillor shenson
thank you chair um yeah i can give you
that assurance i think between yourself
myself and the officers we've got this
covered and we'll be looking out for any
funding indeed i had looked today to
make sure that there was no other
funding available
just at the moment but it is on my
list to check on a regular basis
thank you councillor cleve do you have
any supplements
not at this time thank you chair
thank you and council pair together do
you have any supplement questions
um no but i look forward um for the
portfolio older um sharing this data
when he has it
thank you
um council curtis do you have any
supplementary questions yes thank you
chair um
thank you for this reply um
i think
we're being led to assume that no
pressure is applied to committee members
by the leader of the council or other
members of the cabinet when choosing
their respective chairs and at least i
believe that's what that is what the
leader is suggesting is in his reply
if this is the case that is encouraging
and i'm sure our residents will be
reassured that at least locally the
conservative administration
is not following the prime minister's
lead in avoiding scrutiny by for example
hiding in fridges
bearing this in mind what practical
measures will the leader now take to
ensure that all committee members are
aware of the best practice in
neighbouring councils and following the
guidance of lord evans chair of
committee of standards in public life
thank you chair thank you council
jefferson
thank you chair
uh i think actually making sure that all
members of overview and scrutiny are
fully aware of the rule of overview and
scrutiny and receive the requisite
training is actually a matter for
overview and scrutiny in particular the
chair of overview and scrutiny
thank you and um question nine council
counselor skeletos do you have any
supplementary questions yes i do chair
so
while i understand the uncertainty
around the merger
residents
of and visitors to straw for this
recouncil using these services need
reassurances will the portfolio older
give regular updates once we know the
direction of travel
thank you councillor parker
yes
all right thank you um so now moving on
to item
number 12. uh questions to the leader
please remind members that they have two
questions
per member um in three minutes in total
for each counsellor and only matters
that are
responsibility of the council
um so please make sure your question is
clear so councillor bromwich
yep
so a couple of years ago leader i
brought to your attention about our
private high licensing so i'm going to
declare an interest now as a dual
license holder
and i pointed out that we were very we
desperately need a reform on that
we're now a couple of years down the
line and we are now from what i gather
under siege from our friends from
wolverhampton
licensing the likes of uber and other
private hire operators
this particularly concerns me
because they're moving there because in
particular our outdated policy towards
vehicles and their maximum lifespan
and i also worried about the
accountability then for the possibility
of rogue drivers because i do not see
wolverhampton council
officials coming out here and checking
on these drivers and operators the same
as we would locally
leader can we as a matter of urgency now
have a proper
review and get this issue resolved as
soon as possible i said i first brought
it up to you two years ago
i do not wish to see
the likes of other local authorities
private hire and hack this operate in
this area when we have a very good
standard while greatest one the best in
the country
and i think we can adjust our
guidance our regulations and policies
appropriately and very speedily if we
apply some common sense
uh thank you for the question um
i will take that up with the appropriate
department
i have to say that in the last two years
there has been
quite a lot of
concentration on the curvy pandemic
but i will take it up and see what can
be done thank you
thank you councillor rolf
thank you chair
um councillor jefferson um
i have concerns that this council are
considering
penalizing a section of our older
community
by removing the car park belonging and
alongside the bowls club on the
recreation ground
if the reorganization of the recreation
crown goes ahead
and the car park for the bowls club goes
then this will cause huge problems for a
number of elderly people who are members
of the bowls club and continue to keep
fit during the spring and summer months
some
of those members can't walk very far and
bowl sets can be very heavy and don't
laugh at that because it's quite serious
i've had somebody
already call me this morning about that
i know that discussions have taken place
whereby the council might agree a
certain amount
of concessions on the general car park
for members but this could mean on busy
summer days
those older people parking far away from
the club itself
remember that already the over 65's
concessionary parking has been removed
i know of quite a few people who can no
longer afford to be members of the club
i consider this could be discriminatory
and i would ask the leader to look again
at what can be done
for this section thank you
thank you for your question uh
i think councillor shenton is better
placed to respond than me
thank you
um
good point
um as
you've pointed out uh councillor there
there have been some discussions i've
had one or two uh emails myself about
the situation you're conflating the over
65 by the way uh permit with something
totally separate so i'm not going to
even respond to that part of it
there has been conversations we have
offered um parking spaces as you quite
rightly say there's there's not a lot
else that we can do we're still talking
i know because i spoke to craig uh just
about a week or so ago on this and also
to one of the members
who's connected to the chair there
um
but there is very little else that we
can do we've offered uh spaces in the
main car park
uh we want to we it's part of our
redevelopment that has been put forward
for some time now
i think
it is what it is i mean we will keep
talking but i don't see a resolution on
this coming very quickly
may i have a very quick follow-up chair
to that and ask a question of counselor
shenton please
you may you are so politely
thank you i may not sorry i couldn't
hear
i can't
uh yeah um so can i just can i just
clarify
the spaces you are are saying you will
give concession to are they allocated
spaces
and are they allocated i'm i was told
otherwise but tony is nodding his head
are they allocated near
to the entrance
near to that gate
i think that tony would be better placed
at that
in fairness the questions come a bit
left field for me so that's fine i i
intend to i have said i will call tony
and i will call um tony about this thank
you but are they allocated as far as
you're aware yeah my understanding um
and craig's been dealing with the detail
of it is we need the spaces as part of
this riverside project and we've got an
ongoing conflict with an increasing
amount of sort of use of the bowls club
car parking in area that really should
be reserved for pedestrians
where the mini gold was going so we've
got a conflict there
that was the reason we were seeking to
relocate the um the temporary parking
license that's been granted to the
bolster i've been to the main car park
my understanding is there will be a set
set of identified bollarded car parking
spaces available for the balls club
within the bowl season and we've
done that at a rate that is broadly
comparable with the license fee that
they're paying for the space at the
moment so it will be slightly less
convenient for them that i have to walk
slightly further but craig has been
working with the bowls club um to try
and make sure those spaces are as close
as they can be so as we can try and meet
everybody's needs and sort of keep the
sort of cars away from the pedestrians
and sort of driving around the wreck
which isn't really acceptable in the
long term hope that's helpful thank you
very much thank you oh thank you um
councillor jenny frazier we've all been
circulated the question as well would
you like to read it yeah uh thank you
chair um yeah could the leader explain
the processes that led to the
cancellation of the green bin collection
scheduled immediately after christmas
uh when was the decision taken to cancel
the collection
noting that residents would not have
been aware of it in time for their
preceding uh collection
does cancellation of this collection
constitute a new unilateral breach of a
legal contract made with residents
power residents who have paid for a
green bin and use epic kitchen waste
expected to dispose or store rotting
food waste for four weeks
can you clarify the tree collection
arrangements and dates
noting the risk of extra fly-tipping
caused by the delay
will there be a pro rata reduction to
the next bill to take account of the
missing collection
um
does the leader regard it as
satisfactory that councillors and
residents learnt about this change from
reading it in the newspaper
and would you like to reconsider this uh
decision
thank you so that that's more than two
questions i don't know if council
jefferson wants to summarize and then
maybe do a more specific response
afterwards
uh you are absolutely right here that is
more than two questions
uh in fact i count five
uh
i i would
i will
all i know about the decision to cancel
this collection is that the discussions
i had indicated
that one of the reasons for the decision
was actually because over the christmas
period there is an awful lot more
waste that actually needs to be
collected so shifting from green bin
collections to actually collecting
general household waste seems the best
use of resources
uh i can't answer two
until i've taken legal advice
uh
i can't answer three but i can find out
and get back to you i can't answer four
but i can find out and get back to you
and
question five
i think the answer will be no
uh thank you councillor bromwich
once we
finished
when we adopted our core strategy we
were told by the county council there
was plenty of school places and i
believe i was having this conversation
earlier with the leader
and it actually does involve some family
members but well well wherever for
people experiencing this
they appears that there is a lack of
secondary school places within the
district
would it be possible for the leaders
writes a letter of the appropriate
people
to the county council and asking for
place availability numbers by each year
for each school's catchment areas
because it appears at the moment there
are residents who are struggling who
have moved into the area struggling to
get their kids into schools and
obviously education is very valuable and
we were assured as a council at the
adoption of a course strategy that there
would be places and it appears now that
we do not have places available
thank you i know some of that's county
council but i don't know if you want to
talk about the planning aspect
thank you um as the chair said this is
largely a county council issue
but uh i think
given it relates to the course strategy
and given what you said about the
shortage within the district uh i think
we will investigate and actually
communicate appropriately with the
county council
thank you council curtis
thank you chair um referring to the
issue of the bulls club parking um
mr perks uh mentioned earlier on that um
people will have to walk
further to to the bouldering club and
just like reassurance that the
leader and perhaps councillor shenton
are happy that the removal of this
parking used by older people
doesn't fall foul or won't fall foul of
the equality act 2010 and protect the
characteristics named in that act thank
you
thank you for your question um
i'm not sure we're giving the acoustics
in the room i picked it up fully
obviously within
parking there are two issues
one is that on street parking i believe
is the responsibility of the county
council
and car parks is ours so if there are
issues in our car parks i will take them
up
thank you councillor june adam
um
thank you leader um could i um the camp
transport uh which is a the transport
strategy which is a warwickshire county
council responsibility uh will have a
very vital part to play in this
council's local plan and also this
council's climate change strategy going
forward
would he therefore welcome a study to be
made and support a study to be made by
the ovum scrutiny committee
that could feed into both the local plan
and climate change strategy uh are
looking at transport in this district uh
over
and therefore welcome be able to
feedback
uh to the county i would welcome the
chance to have the county council come
to one of our meetings thank you
thank you councillor junaid
it was quite interesting that uh
as you know i was once chair of lvm
scrutiny committee
one of the things the then leader said
to me at that time was
uh the agenda for overview and scrutiny
committee is up to overview and scrutiny
committee
i hold that to be the case and if
overview and scrutiny wishes to look at
that they are perfectly free to make
that decision to do so
thank you council curtis
thank you chair um thanks for the chance
to
come back to this um i'm sorry about the
acoustic in the room uh leader my
question was
quite specifically with the removal of
this car park or proposed removal of
this car park which is used by all the
people in the main
is the leader and perhaps councillor
shenton happy
that it won't fall foul of the equality
act 2010 and the group of protected
characteristics within that act thank
you
thank you council of course i think to
be honest i would need to take uh proper
advice on that before responding
counselor cleave
thank you chair
uh can i ask in light of the prime
minister's announcement yesterday
regarding the additional booster
vaccines for 18 plus
um can i ask what we're doing as a
council to promote the booster vaccines
i appreciate it doesn't come under
district but we can still promote it so
what are we doing to promote it to our
residents and can i also ask individual
councillors to promote the booster
amongst their own residents as well
please thank you
thank you councillor cleve i think given
the announcement was only made yesterday
we haven't taken any steps to promote it
i think that
until now we haven't taken any steps
to promote it however
i think you are absolutely right and the
individual councillors should
recommend that people get their boosters
thank you do you have any more questions
no
so thank you so much everyone um moving
on to item 13 emotions on notice
uh we've got some motion on tree
planting
uh just saying that just like to thank
everyone for coming to my tree planting
session of the month it was great we did
125 trees so this well done everyone
thank you uh so just to clarify on this
motion uh once proposed and seconded it
will be referred to cabinet for
consideration and report without debate
so please now invites councillor jenny
fraser and susan junior to propose in
second the following
notice of motion
i'd like to propose a motion on tree
planting
and i would like to second that motion
and have it referred to um the cabinet
thank you
so um the next motion is competitive
bits and grants
um and again it will not be debated uh
please may i call upon councillors
curtis and a hencher serif into in
second the following notice
uh hence everything is not here so we'll
look for an alternative one after
councillor curtis has uh proposed the
motors
no worries
yes
like to propose the motion thank you
strictly speaking chair if the if the
seconder isn't here it would fall but
you do have um your inherent
jurisdiction to
allow that to go forward if you wish
yeah i'm wearing a christmas jumper uh
counselor junet would you like a second
yes um i could uh i would urge you to to
seek a desperation the reason why uh
councillor henshi seraphin is not here
is because his wife is in a very
vulnerable state and he cannot afford to
put her her at risk thank you
thank you
so item 14 urgent business um so we this
is the green paper please
and i'd like to
introduce
council jefferson please
uh
or phil grafton may stephen
members um this
report has come to you urgently simply
because
we are trying to react in a positive way
to the latest
announcements on friday of last week
from the prime minister
as you'll read in the report
in the wake of that
the local government association in
particular has renewed its lobbying with
central government about the possibility
of reintroducing
regulations that would either direct or
permit local authorities across the
country to undertake council meetings
remotely
and the idea of the recommendation in
the report is to allow me as monitoring
officer to take advantage in case
government legislation does change
between now and your next meeting which
is not until february
if it does enact
legislation to enable that to happen
that we're in a in a position to react
quickly by changing certain aspects of
the constitution and particularly the
procedure rules to enable virtual
meetings to to actually happen and in
fact if you cast your mind back about a
year
that was exactly what we did the word
there was a table with slight changes to
the different parts of the procedure
rules just to enable those meetings to
take place in a remote um
environment rather than a face-to-face
environment so that that's the basis of
the recommendation thank you
thank you yeah david
thank you chairman and just before
before uh opening up to members um i was
in a briefing on friday with the
department for leveling up um housing
communities where the the minister for
level up kemi bad knock did make the the
stated strongly that
d luck are looking at all measures
possible to try and bring forward those
remote uh meeting provisions so i
support phil's idea that we we really
need to consider this urgently in case
things change between now and our next
council meeting thank you
thank you council jefferson and then
councillor june ed please uh
thank you chair
i think it is really important if there
are
is legislation or regulations passed to
enable remote meetings that we react
quickly i therefore propose we accept
the recommendation uh printed on the on
agenda item 14.
thank you council junit
and i'm prepared to second that that
motion because uh as much as i enjoy
seeing you all face to face i think we
have to consider um the the safety the
only caveat i have is that obviously
when covet is over that we will uh
revert uh to but i i actually do enjoy
meetings online as well as face-to-face
so happy to
um give you the give you that ability in
this one instance to uh change the
constitution
thank you got a couple of questions next
one was councillor bromwich please
yeah
we
this looks like i think this is going to
be cropping up over the next couple of
years time and time again
is there a need to keep every time
legislation changes for us to keep
having to put this as a minor alteration
or can we actually write it to keep him
permanently somehow it would be my
question to the monitoring officer
because it seems a bit ridiculous when
obviously when kobe first came out and i
was one of the group group had nine that
sat here and helped vote this in the
first place we almost came back to the
same thing and it may well be that
simple rewriting the constitution to
allow for such policy and even
impermanently would make more sense
just clarifying that
um
so
the changes to the rules
were
not
some of some of the changes to the rules
would be easier to amend in the way
you're saying that than others
um the other thing to point out was that
the reason those rules came to a to an
abrupt end if you remember i think it
was the 7th of may this year was simply
because government refused to extend
them despite
very strong lobby lobbying from the
whole of the local government community
i think at the moment we just need to
get these
rules back into place should should
legislation change but we'll have a look
at that to see whether we could
provide a more
anodyne
version of the constitution which would
mean we could operate it
whether virtual or not
thank you councillor harvey
thank you chairman um
i'm under the impression that this whole
process is driven by legislation so it's
a matter of conformity and as far as the
proposal is concerned i'm totally happy
with it my concern however is that
the same practice is not always adopted
by town and parish councils
i know for instance that there is this
evening
a town council
meeting arranged
to be held remotely as as i understand
matters
that is not allowed
until
until the government makes up its mind
what it wants to do and tells
local government authorities and that
they can vary their their face-to-face
requirement to virtual meetings that
parish councils town councils are not at
liberty to
take the initiative even if they think
the law is an ass and we may agree with
that
they are not in that position could mr
grafton uh confirm that that is the case
and please confirm that it is in his
intention to advise all parish and town
councils just exactly what they can do
and can't do and when they can do it
please
i agree with your
uh position that in fact my
understanding is that no local
authorities at whatever tier can at
present operate
virtual meetings to run their
decision-making meetings
i i make a distinction because of course
we do have some meetings within the
council that operate virtually but then
crucially that no they're not decision
making meetings um in terms of
me liaising with um
individual town and parish councils on
that point i'm quite happy to put
something out having said that welk is
their representative body and i would
imagine that they have been advising
their members accordingly although of
course it's true that not all town and
parish councils are members of welk so
in essence i i agree with the position
the legal position and yes i i will
write to town and parish councils to
give them
my advice although of course it has to
be said that they are separate legal
entities from the district council and
they can do
what they think they
should do in other words i don't have
any any right to tell them what to do
thank you councillor kettle did you have
a question no
okay counselor rock
uh thank you chairman i very much
support this motion
and recommendation
i just wanted to make one or two other
points and i um i thank trevor uh
councillor harvey for the point that
he's made about parish councils
um some of us have got a lot of parish
councils and they don't have the
capacity
to uh
handle social distancing and so forth
including mine and it is quite a problem
so um
councillors will be aware that they read
their emails that um i wrote to my mp as
jeremy wright
and received a positive response from
him that he would contact government
ministers in this regard
because frankly it is
it is a nonsense that the prime
minister's standing up and asking
everybody to work from home and then
forcing us to meet it in this way
uh i i do hope when we've done this we
get given the option and don't get
forced to do something that is
inappropriate the other way
um
but i would ask uh all members to make
whatever noises they can in whatever
corridors of power exists to give us
that those options in the future and do
something sensible and and explore some
consistent measurement
measures that come out of government so
please do that and i'm sure i know that
officers because i've had a number of
conversations with officers about this i
know they're working hard to to bring
that pressure to bear to officers
channels as well um so i very much
support the proposal thank you very much
chairman
thank you councillor barker
i just wanted to add that uh the point
that's been made about uh
decision-making meetings and my
understanding is that the meeting to
which councillor harvey refers is a
decision-making meeting
and people will be participating
remotely
great thank you so we've got a proposal
and second are we in agreement
wonderful thank you
so um now i'll be adjourning the meeting
and we'll meet again at six o'clock to
consider proposal to create a southwark
district council thank you
that's it
tested
councillors can you take your seats
please
that's
welcome back councillors and thank you
for um for joining us going to hand over
now to david buckland just to give an
update on the apologies
thank you chairman if you recall i i
didn't know councillor crump has been
absent i'm glad to see councillor crump
has joined us for item number 15 as has
councillor o'donnell and councillor
pemberton thank you chairman
thank you so now we continue on item 15
the proposal to create a south
warwickshire district council and i'd
like to invite council jefferson as
leader of the council to introduce this
item
thank you chair
we have an extensive
and comprehensive report in front of us
i am not going to go through every
detail in that comprehensive report
instead i've got a few key points i wish
to make
first
this is a major strategic decision
we shall be taken with the benefits for
residents at the top of our minds
it's the biggest decision
we as councillors have been asked to
make
we need to focus on the strategic issues
and not matters of detail
it's not a comparison of a south
warwickshire district council with the
existing stratford district council and
warwick district council
it's about the future prospects
for a south warwickshire district
council
set against the future prospects for
separate stratfor district and warwick
district councils
it's also very specifically
not about unitary councils
that option is not on the table
if that option comes onto the table then
we will have to address that issue as
and when it arises
we're not here to second guess what may
there was a statement from the district
council's network today which outlined
the department for leveling up housing
and communities official position
as
there are no plans
and reorganization remains a locally led
avenue available
and what we are proposing is locally led
why do i think this is the right
decision from a council
number of reasons one of which is the
financial position within is challenging
the finance background leaves as little
room for maneuver
corvids exacerbated all the pressures on
us
and the economic background for the uk
is fraught
so it'd be unrealistic to expect much
help from central government
the alternatives to merging
are likely to be unpalatable
where they cut services
and raise charges
or continue spending to the point where
the section 151 officer
issues a section 114 notice
that means we would effectively be broke
i have to say i don't think we'd ever
get to that stage but those are the
stark options
frankly a lot of other councils are
burying their heads in the sand
about their financial situation and that
certainly is the feedback that we've had
what we are doing is seeking to take
control of our own destiny
this merge is not just about costs and
finance however there are significant
positive opportunities
we're already seeing benefits in the
joint waste contract
and the development of the south
warwickshire local plan
a south warwickshire district council
will have far greater influence
it will for example
have the second largest growth value
added
in the west midlands after birmingham
we have informed and discussed what we
are proposing with local mps and the
mayor of the west midlands combined
authority
with one exception
all have been supportive and positive
it's also been discussed with officials
in the department for leveling up
housing and communities
they have allocated an official to help
with the process
there has been absolutely no indication
we should not submit a proposal
indeed given the department's official
position i stated earlier it would be
hard to see how they could object
it would not be exaggerating to say that
our decision will have national
significance
and a lot of people will be watching
closely particularly given what i said
about the financial position of the
councils
it'll be over two years before the new
council comes into existence
a lot can happen in two years
and frankly we will be far more
resilient together
there is a view
that we can merge services but not merge
politically
i think this would prove to be unstable
the experience of warwickshire and west
middle mercier police does not bode well
for this option
one body with two heads
seldom works well
a word i tell you about the consultation
exercise
if we look at the open survey
only about 0.7
of the electorate responded
1441 of 217
426.
telephone survey in stratford
60
of respondents agreed with the proposal
to merge
and only 31 disagreed
the majority was 29
so
as district councillors and i stress
district councillors it would appear to
me that we have a pretty clear mandate
we clearly meet the three tests set by
government
they will improve the area's local
government
there's evidence of a good deal of local
support
and the area is a credible geography
there's
ample evidence for all of these in
paragraph three
of the report
i have to caution that today is just the
first or the most significant step
there'll be a lot of work still to do
a lot of details to be hammered out
i would also like to stress that these
will not all be under our control
but i can assure you we will fight hard
to ensure our views are heard
especially on issues such as the number
of councillors
i will repeat what i said earlier this
is a strategic decision for us all
acting as district councillors
any counselor thinking of opposing the
proposals
should ask themselves what they think
the alternative
viable strategy would be
i believe strongly that the merger is in
the best interests of the residents of
stratford on avon district and south
warwickshire as a whole
and i propose we accept all the
recommendations to council contained in
the paper
i now seek a second
thank you council power for seconding
um i would now uh
let's see if there's any other members
like speaker councillor harvey
thank you mr chairman
i've been struck by the similarity
between the way this proposal has been
presented to members of the council and
the way in which a planning application
would be presented to the planning
committee
we've been presented with a substantial
report that sets out the arguments
and evaluates the evidence that's been
collected in relation to this proposal
the body of the report is supported by
numerous appendices that provide the
detail of the evidence upon which the
officer's report is based
the evidence gathered and here presented
demonstrates that all of the
government's three criteria by which
such an application is to be assessed
have each been met
first
the proposed council will improve the
area's local government
because it will provide a sounder
financial basis to enable it to defend
its provision of services
second there is credible and
independently verified evidence that the
proposal enjoys a good level of support
locally
and third the two districts are adjacent
and are already operating in ways that
demonstrate their ability to work
jointly
of course unlike a planning application
there's no explicit officer's
recommendation to grant this application
so to speak
the responsibility for this decision is
down solely to the councillors in this
chamber
the issue of how local government in
south warwickshire can best be secured
for the future is the most important and
the highest level strategic decision
this council will take
the evidence from deloitte
from the lga
from the ors consultation process
amongst others all support the case for
the new council
are there risks and
uncertainties in taking this step well
of course there are a merger is neither
a panacea nor a guarantee of future
success
based on the evidence that's been
gathered and weighed and evaluated
however
not only does this proposal satisfy the
government's criteria for a decision to
travel this path
it's the path that has the greatest
potential to ensure that the residents
of south workshop will continue to
receive in future both the statutory and
the discretionary services to which they
are accustomed
to revert to the planning application
analogy
if the officers had concluded paper with
the recommendation
i have no doubt it would have been to
approve the proposal
but this is not a matter for decision by
officers it's a decision for the
district's councillors
if we go to article 2 of the council's
constitution
we find set out there that the primary
role of a counselor the role above all
else
is to represent the electorate to the
council
to participate in community leadership
and also in the determination of the
strategic direction of the council
and in fulfilling this role
every councillor is required by the
council's code of conduct
amongst other things to act solely in
terms of the public interest
to avoid placing themselves under any
obligation to people or organizations
that might try inappropriately to
influence them
and they must act and take decisions
impartially
fairly and on merit
using the best evidence
and without discrimination or bias
along with 33 other members of this
council
i voted earlier in february of this year
in favor of the vision statement for the
creation of a south warwickshire
district council
my view is the best evidence we now have
before us
evaluated impartially
fairly and unmerit
indicates that the proposal before us
the former south warwickshire district
council deserves my support
for those who despite their previous
support for the same vision statement
feel they have subsequently come to a
different view
let them present their evidence not
merely their opinions or their
assertions let them present their
evidence that either suggests that the
three governments government the
government's three criteria have not
been met
or that despite the criteria having been
met they have some other compelling
evidence that suggests an alternative
strategy should be adopted
and if that is the case what is that
alternative strategy and what is the
case for it
the pro proposal we are now discussing
on the other hand
is the cons result of considerable
thought
much consultation and extensive
deliberation
the evidence is before you all
so you can exercise your judgment
for my own part and in the long term
interests of the residents of the
district this proposal has my full
support
thank you mr chairman thank you the next
hand i saw was uh councillor ian shenson
please
thank you chair
excuse me for this first quote but to be
south warwickshire district council not
to be
uh and my apologies
to william shakespeare for putting the
twist on the famous line from hamlet
we've come out we've come a long way
over the last year
especially when you consider it's been
against the backdrop
of kobit 19 and a disastrous fire at the
material recycling facility in eddington
part of my portfolio covers waste and
this touches every household within sdc
and wdc
no other service reaches
and affects everyone quite like waste
collection
when we look at services both wdc and
ourselves have invested in the new
partners in what will be the most
advanced facility in europe and possibly
the world will be the first facility in
this country to be able to take plastic
film
between us we'll have the largest
combined share in the facility but we
have duplicated time costs and
administration in getting this far
we've entered into a joint contract for
waste collection
investing in more eco-friendly refuge
trucks more efficient routes and
standardizing the way waste is collected
as part of this we're introducing the
collection of food waste the head of the
government mandating this
also we'll need to distribute over 60
000 blue bins to the residents of wdc
all of this has been done with the two
authorities teams working together under
the excellent head of service julie
lewis
however effectively we've duplicated the
procurement decision making and approval
processes getting sign off from two
organizers excuse me two organizations
to one contract
with regards to the vehicles we've
talked at length and agreed that whilst
we would want electric or
hydrogen-powered refuse trucks now is
not the right time again we've had to
incur time costs administration and
reach a position that was agreeable and
practical for both authorities
we will be working across borders and
effectively it is a south warwickshire
contract
but because we're two separate
authorities we incur unnecessary
administration separating costs and
accounting
looking at my other role climate change
arguably the biggest part of my role at
present
we've have again had to not only reach
agreement jointly but also get agreement
within our own authorities
we've agreed the three ambitions and a
detailed plan supporting this but
funding the ambitions and the detailed
uh funding the ambitions separately is
not the best use of funds two sets of
members two sets of approval processes
and yet we managed to reach a landing
point but again the time and cost of
reaching this point has been duplicated
adding extra uncertainty into the
process
we want the same things we care about
the same issues and we want to do as
much as we can to adapt and mitigate
change
but the process despite the best efforts
of the director for climate change day
day baba is tortuous
the two authorities think broadly the
same we want to bring more contracts
together have a consistent strong and
robust approach to climate change and do
as much as we can to adapt to mitigate
the effects making the best use of the
funds we have available and delivering
services in the most cost effective way
across our border
there are so many shared ambitions goals
and areas of agreement within operations
and climate change
but so much wasted costs and
administration and duplication of effort
one new district council one
administration able to leverage funds
more easily to achieve one set of goals
it makes sense
working together set the tone of a
partnership going forward but it can
never deliver the savings and the pace
of change especially in the case of
climate change that is necessary
what is needed is a brand new south
warwickshire district the creation of a
new council not just the merger of two
councils
a new council that can act at pace be
agile respond quickly to the challenges
that operations and undoubtedly climate
change will bring
we cannot afford to stand still and not
merge fully in the creation of a new
south warwickshire district council to
stand still
is to go backwards we must move forward
to maximize the benefits of one waste
contract one leisure contract one public
toilets contract one street cleaning
contract one recycling contract
and one consistent approach the greatest
threat to the planet
climate
change so i'll end as i've started
to be or not to be
and that is the question
i urge you to support the
recommendations within the papers
thank you thank you council for check
thank you chairman
having looked at and read the evidence
along with other considerations
i believe it would not be of benefit to
the residents of clotton nor the wider
area of the stratford district
to abolish stratfor district council for
south warwickshire district council
my first concern is of a democratic
deficit
ultimately a south warwickshire district
council will have less councillors
making each ward significantly bigger
taking councillors further away from the
residents
according to the recent district
council's network report
which shows 300 pieces of independent
research is conclusive
that larger councils lead to falling
public trust
falling engagement and a reduced sense
of belonging to their local area
and council
the research also concluded that larger
councils do not make a difference in
quality or efficiency of services
i also have concerns about council tax
harmonisation
it may be that residents in clotton and
the widest traffic district will see
significant rises in council tax for the
next seven years to catch up with what
warwick district council taxpayers
already paying
also deloitte say that significant
savings can be made by moving out of
both head office buildings of sdc and
warwick district council
i was saying this in 2015 that stratfor
district council should be relocating
so significant savings can be made
without a merger
also quite clearly cost savings can be
made through sharing services without
political harmonization
my other concern
is that the conservatives didn't tell
residents these plans in may 19 2019 at
the elections
was this deliberate were they fearful of
losing seats if these plans were
disclosed before the election
why not wait until the next election and
put these plans before the electorate
this whole process appears to be rushed
and is happening at breakneck speed
lastly we cannot underestimate the
emotional attachment local residents
have with their council with their
stratfor district council
because of its size and relevance
with our community stretching back over
many decades
including its relevance as a borough
council before 1974
as we've seen by the surveys done there
is no enthusiastic appetite for the need
of a super council
this will make it harder to meet the
needs of its residents
this will not bring it closer to its
residents this will not bring
better decision making for its residents
in the long term this super council will
not bring better local government to the
residents of clopton nor to the
residents of the stratfor district
therefore i'll be voting against the
proposal to abolish this council to
create a south warwickshire district
council thank you chair
thank you councillor wally hoggins
it will come as no surprise to anyone in
this council chamber or those viewing
from the comfort of their homes across
the united kingdom
that the ladies are not for turning
in an email to tony jefferson the
current leader of this great council i
wrote
my views on the merger with warwick and
levington haven't changed and the
consultation has served to strengthen my
views and position further
the lack of responses only 482 in
stratford-upon-avon in the consultation
shows us that our residents quite simply
don't want to engage in what amounts to
nothing more than a paper exercise
the lack of responses across the
district clearly demonstrates that it
was designed not to engage the public in
their views and their hopes for their
futures as residents
it was done by those that seek a mandate
to destroy and obliterate the great
council that is stratfor district
council
this very expensive consultation was
done as a tick box exercise in the vain
hope that it will satisfy government
requirements to have sought public
opinion on a merger
central government will throw this
proposal out it will be yet another
embarrassment like the judicial review
that this conservative council
instigated against its own conservative
government i doubt very much that that
and a defined course of action will have
been forgotten or forgiven
we are continually told there is no
alternative i know that this is not true
i do not want the residents of stratford
on avon to be subsidizing the lifestyles
of very senior officers at warwick and
levington one of whom has spent the last
two years conducting most of their
council work remotely from wales and
another who permanently resides in
liverpool both of these will benefit
from six figure salary packages
theirs is a council whose doors to its
public are not open
where the old and the frail and the
vulnerable must seek an appointment
before they can enter a building
are we to before the same fate as the
residents of warwick and levington whose
lives are governed and managed like this
a vote for this merger will do just that
to each and every member of staff
who is fearful that they are going to
lose their job and are making
adjustments to their christmas
celebrations and spending on their
children's presence and losing sleep at
night over their futures i want you to
know that i hear you
seventy percent of those working for
this council do not belong to a union
they have no powerful voice as they see
the district that they have dedicated
their working lives to unravel before
their eyes
their expertise is being watered down
they are being asked to do the same job
across two districts so our council tax
is now paying for members of staff
including heads of star service
to work for two two and a half days for
us and two and a half days for warrick
and levington this is wrong
there is an alternative and that is a
single unity council of warwickshire
which may safeguard more jobs ensure
high standards in all aspects of
statutory and non-statutory services
including a vitally important health
social care and education where leaders
and executives are of the highest
possible caliber and are already used to
working for the greater good of all
residents of warwickshire including
stratford-upon-avon
without bias
my concern is that is this whole
escapade is driven by the resentment of
some about the exceptional capabilities
of warwickshire and its leader
this proposal to join the two councils
together gives a clear evidence base as
to why there has to be radical reform of
local government as outlined or was it
leaked in the independent on friday
it is precisely because local
governments can spend tens of thousands
of pounds of public money without a
conscience
on consultations and reports
or a backward glance for that matter the
reform is coming
the vote today is worthless we have not
been given a mandate that those elected
us to join together with warwick and
levington
482 responses out of a total population
now in excess of 130 000 is not .3
and that gives us no authorization to do
anything at all and no authority to say
yes to anything
stratfor district council and its
reputation has been built laboriously
and steadily over many years by
generations of dedicated counselors and
officers
this
will be destroyed by a yes vote today
thank you councillor wally hoggins uh
councillor junit
i'm a former leader of this council
i was a leader for three years
can i just say
that although i admire very much this
district council and its officers
that it has had substantial cuts from
government over many many years
and it has lost some insignificant
number of services since i remember
being a counselor it back in 1990s
so it is not true to say that we're at
the epitome of our performance here we
have been under significant financial
pressure from government over many years
all councils have been under significant
financial pressure for many years
and we've had to make cuts in services
so we no longer have actually to service
services that cover tourism and culture
or services that directly uh have the
economic development service in-house as
we used to do
or
many other other services as well so
that is why why i have taken a long long
time to start to consider
what what my particular view is
i know that we've been told that the
white paper will not be available to
next year and we've been told that what
is it has been reported in the
independent is not a true reflection of
thinking however there's also been
another story in the local government
chronicles so i think there must be some
truth somewhere behind that there will
be a
emerging of council areas into bigger
economic units
can i make it quite clear
that i do not want a merger
that would make make it to be a council
county council unitary warwickshire
county council unitary do you know what
the tax harmonization will be there
that will be from north to south it will
be over a hundred pounds between uneaten
bed earth and stratford
just to put that into into context
i have been
thinking about this for quite some years
and quite some time
actually this is the third time that
this has been raised as a subject within
within this um district council area
since about the 1990s
the herald actually covered this unitary
a year ago and there were letters in the
press and there were stories in the
press
and so people were informed that there
was this coming along
and for me
what is being presented what the
services that are available to residents
is the thing that matters most not
political nothing like that at all it is
what i have been about all my life as as
a counselor what is best for residents
and stratford and warwick district
councils are do have many similarities
there are some differences i have
actually um had a working
experience with warwick district council
they cover most of the south of the
county
and by working together we can actually
save camps money for council tech tax
payers
but more than that
much much more than that is whether we
can deliver better services and create a
more resilient and effective council
we do all face uh
similar challenge challenges for the
future
and i do one of the things that has
decided me
is the challenge of affordable housing
for our young people
this is something that i feel very very
strongly about from from ulster
i think we've had 1.9 percent of any of
the affordable housing over the last 10
years uh has been in ulster
and we
we're having a real problem
it's not just affordable social housing
it is affordable housing per se for our
young young people i've got children who
found it difficult living in this area
but i've got grandchildren who will find
it even more difficult living in this
area
so i want to make sure that we've got
affordable housing for young people
the thing that has driven me for a long
time is climate change and i need to see
that though we are working together on
climate change
carbon emissions do not stop at borders
and we just happen to have some major
roads within this area that where we can
do some major work if we work together
and we must and we have to deliver
better quality services
so i did something proactive with my
group
i asked for certain best practice to be
written into the report
i took that opportunity then not waiting
until today to ask four things i waited
did it before when i could hand and did
have the chance to do something
so in that report it says quite clearly
that we as liberal democrats
want best practice in the provision of
affordable housing
we want maximum engagement with parish
and town councils and that means that
some of the responsibilities if there
are is capabilities and agreement will
go to paris and town councils
that there will be a program of
cooperation in planning and climate
change that will be a world-class best
practice
a review of the governance because i do
think we need to have a review of
governments and how this council
operates and that needs to be widespread
but it also needs to have the input of
councillors or councillors
to make sure that there is proper
democratic representation and i do not
want to see a major democratic deficit
so it must be part of the ongoing that
we we should should do that
and then we want ongoing consultation on
how best to deliver quality local
services to local communities
and if anybody doubts that we did that
those demands are reflected in the
report to councillors on page 22 of the
report to cabinet
and they must be delivered for me to to
be able to carry on uh with this
but more than that accounts junior if we
can wrap that up please yeah more than
that
there is to be a working group
can i ask and have assurance that all
councillors will be included
unable to play their part going forward
so that any differences of opinion here
in this chamber today could be properly
uh worked out and uh
and acted upon what's this decision it
is not the decision that we made today
this is a decision to go to the minister
and the work will begin afterwards
thank you so much uh councillor kettle
counselors
i'm in support of this proposal which as
the leader has said is a strategic
decision about an issue for which we
cannot stand still
the future of service delivery for our
residents
we cannot stand still
that much as though we might like to
i will repeat this is a decision about
strategy
having said that when the decision is
made later today there will still be a
huge amount of work still to be done
and a lot of issues and details to be
resolved
and the joint arrangements steering
group a non-political group has
demonstrated how members of the two
councils working together can resolve
those issues
and how the benefits of working together
can be achieved
much already since that group was
initiated
and that work will continue right up to
the moment when we do consider the
formal merger at some point in the
future
just as councillor schensen has pointed
out the benefits in his portfolio of
joint working
part of my own portfolio community
safety has been working together
with warwick district council for some
years
and this has also been demonstrably
successful
that like any merger
there is still much
work to be done much to be resolved does
not mean that we cannot and should not
support this strategy
this merger is the right direction for
both councils
standing still
for whatever reason
is no longer
an option
councillors and colleagues
i would invite you to support this
exciting and challenging opportunity
um because it is in the best interests
of
our residents who elect us to deliver
services
with the officers of this council
to for their benefit thank you
thank you councillor perticola
um if the submission
for the merger proposal is passed later
today
we need to ensure as consular junaid has
just stated that there is no delusion of
a letter electoral representation and
this has been raised as a great concern
by fellow councillors
further any future governance model must
give proper representation across what
would be a much larger geographical area
therefore we seek reassurances that a
future joint working group will also
have in its strategic remit a review of
democratic governance to give best
representation including
the exploration of the committee system
of governance where decisions are made
by committees of counselors from all
parties and none
rather than by very few counselors in
the current leader and cabinet model
such committee system could provide the
people of a southwestern district with a
louder voice in local decision making
thank you
thank you councillor bromwich
yeah i'm going to start off by quoting a
historical line not a bit of shakespeare
this time so in 1961
john f kennedy just after
the first american orbits planet earth
announced that america was going to go
to the moon
not because it was easy because it is
hard
that is the first point to take away
from this
whatever decision is made tonight
it is going to be hard going forward
so i have been on the steering group
going through this with fellow
councillors from both areas i've seen
the reports are given out but i decided
to expand with a bit of research
so my first guidance i was looking for
was
any successful example in recent years
of a local authority merger that's
actually saved money
the answer is at the moment
deloitte gave the figures to say they
did but none of them have but bear in
mind one was a very exceptional
circumstance the other two are quite new
still so that debate is probably
a little bit iffy but it shouldn't ever
be just about finances
we've known for a number of years many
of us sitting here that there's been
money troubles brewing
not just because of kobe that problem
has been underlined for many years
and in many ways we've been in trouble
in transition as a group of councils no
political group to brain
that we haven't made some bolder and
braver decisions in the past
so i am very concerned about the claims
of financial savings because
at the moment there is no example that
is actually there
the next part i would went on to was
looking at ward member sizes
on average those ward sizes have gone up
from 2
100 to 4 000.
that's a big jump
and having looked at what our numbers
are here
we could be
if we don't get this right in danger of
going to those sort of levels as well
so that is also worth bearing in mind
what we do know as well is from
the various market researching has gone
on is that there's a lot of apathy out
there
and has been pointed out very few
respondents
and lead i have to take issue you when
you've selected a 60 figure in favor via
one section when we know on the online
section there was a majority against
it's very realistic it's probably a 50
50 the split of respondents for whatever
reasons
on that
we have to be very careful when we say
there is overwhelming support because
there is not that overwhelming support
there's been
many people in the public who have
approached myself i've been very
critical of the lack of proper
engagement indeed myself and council
trump actually held a
surgery and saw them and we also dealt
with a number of online respondents
again a lot of people are very edgy
about this especially when it comes to
council tax and i know we're being told
that's where new council determined
but bear this in mind out of those
examples i mentioned earlier about local
authority mergers
one of those mergers in suffolk they
actually harmonize the council tax
beforehand
because it made things better for
residents to understand
at the moment my good feeling is we have
tried to push this through too quick
we've got
proper residential engagement not
guiding enthusiasm out there at the
moment
and we could be susceptible ultimately
to five percent of an electorate wanting
to use the localism act for a referendum
if we are not careful
because the law does give them that
scope to actually do that
on balance at the moment
i would say i'll say i'm minded not to
support the proposal as it stands
because the full facts are not out there
we have
some basic ideas we have a lot of
suggestions possibilities
but because of speed we tried to do this
we've not carried the public with us to
a good enthusiastic level
we have not turned around and put such a
great case everyone's going to turn
around and say actually that's a great
idea 30 seconds please we have got to a
state a moment where we have an idea
but we're not
fully rounded of that idea and
councillors if you vote for this today
you are voting for something that's not
a complete package yet to sell to your
residents
thank you councillor jennings
am i on
both districts have to be in a sound
financial position in order to offer
non-statutory services to the people of
the districts
there's no big there's no magic money
tree
we have to make savings and the only way
to do that is for both
districts to merge the money's not
coming from anywhere else
tourism it brings in 800 million into
our economies it it's vital
sdc and wdc are both the main finances
behind the dmo
shakespeare's england
we don't want to cut this we want to
enhance it we want to focus on creating
an in-demand south warwickshire
offering like a five-day
trip
like a
visit to the british motion museum the
dallas burst and polo club
lambton spa gardens and pump rooms what
kent warwick castle kenworth castle
henley ice cream i was going to check
that one in there
and stratford all stratford has to offer
before going off to shipstand and off
into the sunset
however no funds no dmo no tourists
shop closures we know what despite how
the spiral goes
do you want the same thing for arts and
culture well bringing rural cinema and
arts to the wider community something
you want to enhance not cut
we intend to launch a regular joint
newsletter to promote south warwickshire
arts and culture in the new year but as
always this depends on funds being
available
we're investing in leisure facilities
and we want to in the future vital in
the current circumstances but to do so
needs funds
i also attended west midlands combined
authority in the cw let meetings
they both see the economic development
potential of south warwickshire district
especially the green automotive corridor
stretching from jlr and lotus up to the
projected gigafactory in warwick
district
we have a large number of multinationals
looking to move into south warwickshire
why
because they see the strategic value and
the potential of the area which is only
enhanced by a merged council with the
same goals and aspirations
whitehall's announced that they'll be
local government reform well we don't
know when so there's no point in
guessing at that but a good business
will plan for the future and all
eventualities
if we want to be in a position to manage
our own destiny we have to show or
demonstrate that we're capable
of with our finances and we have the
ability to make hard decisions
and actually make them
and this isn't a party political
decision it doesn't benefit any
particular party this is a common sense
decision to enable you to continue
offering local representation and
services to your ward members no matter
what their political views are
let's not be scared of change let's
embrace it be bold be brave be positive
and do the right things for the people
in our communities and vote for this
merger
thank you councillor o'donnell
thank you chair um
i thought it might be useful briefly for
members who weren't at the cabinet i may
not have seen the osc meeting just to
quickly outline what we discussed
because we looked at it from a strategic
perspective so to just briefly outline
that it might help with deliberations
and so we almost run onto four hours so
we went through things quite thoroughly
um but with my chair of osc house i
would just like to quickly take this
opportunity to thank my wonderful
committee members who scrutinized the
merger proposal so thoroughly and
without predetermination members thank
you you took your time it's been valued
and remember you did that
unquestioningly with any parity of
respect
um thank you to the officers who've
supported us without question if even
though they're facing increased
workloads at this busy and relentless
time of year and we welcome our new
scrutiny support officer jack to our
team moving forward to keep scrutinizing
this this merger
the osce scrutiny of the report was
based around five themes and feedback
has been related to each of these and it
just might help you clarify a few points
today
around the consultation the committee
welcomed the consultation exercise and
felt that it had been easily accessible
through the council website and the view
magazine
risk
and finance was our second theme and
concerns continually were raised about
ensuring that all the potential savings
were achievable in the areas of
democracy and office costs the process
for leveling up council tax between two
authorities would need considerable
levels of consideration around how this
was approached and
presented to our residents and it was
also felt that training around the
potential for the housing revenue
account to cover the whole of the south
warwickshire area would be valuable we
also looked at services and members
needed to be clear about the benefits
that the merger would actually bring to
residents and parishes the merge
potentially would give the opportunity
to look at more innovative delivery of
services and improving service
resilience but not much detail was on
the bones democratic representation as
you've heard throughout representations
this evening people were concerned
around the number of councillors for the
new council and that we would need to
ensure that there were sufficient
councillors to operate the number of
committees that would be required to
effectively operate the merged
organization and then climate emergency
a single entity would be much better
place to deliver a consistent programme
to address climate change as you've also
heard supported by councillors um
junod and
councillor shenton in general we
acknowledge that to date what had been
produced was a useful framework but
there was more detailed work to be done
to turn this proposal into an
operational council
now as ward member i do have some
concerns i am concerned that our sample
size was too small at 0.7 of our
population i'm thrilled that my
ettington ward had the highest level of
engagement in our district to the open
questionnaire but the statisticians are
unable to provide ward results
as to what those responses were as a
sample size award by award would be too
small to be reliable so great engagement
eddington ward thank you but i'm none
the wiser as to how you voted
i do know concerns were raised at my
parishes around the number of
councillors
around the level of services and about
losing our identity as a district
especially our rural voice and
representing a rural district that is a
concern to me now financial difficulties
have been discussed for many years at
stratford
and a heavy reliance perhaps on the new
homes bonus made us less than proactive
around generating more income
highlighting to me a lack of vision and
creativity and this merger is solely
financially based it is not a utopian
vision between stratford and warwick and
this is my area of concern if we have
shown a lack of vision and creativity in
the past how can you guarantee us as
members and how can we guarantee our
residents that we will not be in the
same situation again
because there is a high risk that we
will lose our identity and if we
continue to take this top down rather
than grasp grassroots upwards approach
this merger we are risking
being back in the same situation again
and this cannot be allowed after all
none of us stood on a mandate as a super
district councillor we stood as
councillors for stratfor district
council
we need more meat on the bones you know
what will the actual savings be what
will the staff redundancies be because
our staff deserve
to know more about the actual facts on
savings their loyalty is unwavering and
ask to them should be too what will
happen
thank you what will happen about
councillor sizes and we need a
consistent and constant dialogue and a
collaborative approach with this merger
with our major stakeholders as well as i
said in the last council meeting
regarding this it is surprising that we
had not discussed this with our largest
council neighbor
but if i do vote for this this evening
it will be with a heavy heart because
the above reasons
but i do think we need to look at what
will the true savings be what will our
council numbers be and how will we
maintain our identity as a rural
district thank you thank you councillor
perry
thank you chairman
i'm particularly pleased and delighted
to second this proposal
to create a single statutory south
warwickshire council
and firstly would like to express my
thanks to all the teams in bringing
forward this excellent and well-honed
document
which represents hours and hours of work
which has been undertaken with great
diligence and a forensic approach with
no stone unturned
this evening's proposed merger proposals
positives
far outweigh the negatives
as someone with first-hand experience of
a merger
i can confirm
that no mergers are easy
but the importance of this one is that
we have the full backing of our chief
executive
and the senior management team
together with the majority of staff and
this is a critical success factor that
is required
whilst one needs to recognize the
current gap between the council tax
of stratfor district council and warwick
district council of 27 pounds
we must also remember the increases
already residents
have paid this year to warwickshire
county council of 4.99
which is 72 pounds
on a d-rate banned property and an
increase of six point three percent to
warwickshire police of fifteen pounds
which in total represents an increase
this year alone of eighty-seven pounds
almost 60 percent
of stratfor district council's total
council tax to each bandy uh resident
it's also extremely likely that the
increases
both warwickshire county council and the
warwickshire police will impose us on us
all next year are likely to be in excess
of three figures
but it is important to note
that this gap between the districts
would be closed over a period of time
not in one go
however
not voting for the merger would result
in this council being financially
unsustainable
resulting in significant cuts to our
services
inevitable redundancies
plus
further increases in council tax anyway
the benefits that i see are considerable
and whilst there are too many to mention
i will just highlight a few
from a workforce point of view a super
district offers a greater level of
development and therefore is more
attractive to staff and the job market
having a larger pool of staff in the
current smaller function areas
means that capacity can be increased in
those departments hit by long-term
sickness
in the focus groups staff members
recognized that the merger could
represent opportunities to maintain and
improve service position provision and
to address key challenges
the knowledge pool would be increased in
specialist areas which means an
increased skill set in delivery terms to
our residents
the focus groups reflect the real
picture and indicated more support for
the proposed merger as they recognize
that this would provide an opportunity
to safeguard the services provision to
residents in the face of financial
challenges
a number of parish and town councils
have also recognized the potential of
improved economies of scale with a
larger and stronger local authority
which i'm pleased to say also includes
wellsborne and walton parish council
i'd also like to highlight in particular
that it's actually a win-win for all our
parish and council councils particularly
those east of the m40
and in particular southam who will then
be much closer to the a bigger hub and
center of a larger district
rather being the furthest point of
stratfor district council
in a nutshell
as far as i'm concerned it's a no brain
it's a no-brainer as in case as in this
case there is no plan b from a financial
perspective which would result in less
servicing services costing more
please do the right thing in the best
interests of all your residents
and staff
by supporting these merger proposals
this evening thank you
thank you councillor barker
thank you mr chairman
um
i'm delighted so many people this
evening have mentioned the words bold
and brave and making bold and brave
decisions because this is one
there's no doubt about that
um i completely concur with councillor
bromwich on that one
and i'd like to just remind us that we
are here as representatives and that
representative democracy
is not always comfortable and it is
about
leading we're now here to turn the
vision that we had in february
into the beginnings of a new political
reality
and making the submission to the
secretary of state
for me this is a really positive move
and i'll tell you why
particularly within my own portfolio
one of the
things that comes up most frequently
whether it's at osc my own post bag all
your post bags email bags housing
orbit in particular
other housing associations are available
but
that is a huge huge
issue for all of us and i know how
passionately we all feel about it and
are trying to sort things out
so
the benefit for me
of joining with warwick
is that already they have massive
massive experience of running an hr a
housing revenue account which is how you
run these things
because they didn't sell their
council housing
in the first place they hung onto it
and so they are used to dealing with it
they've got a big portfolio and
by working with them and going in with
them in housing we're going to give our
residents
the opportunity to have a landlord that
might be different
just might be
and over which we will have more
influence as councillors and i think
that that is something that across the
board we can agree on um
we do
need real affordable housing absolutely
support what council junit says there
and and i try very very hard to hint
from time to time what i'm up to in the
background
talking about a housing revenue account
and talking about the housing company
and those things will become a reality
and we will be part of it
when we join boric we won't just be part
we will be an influential part we will
be half of it
and we will be leading in that area for
our residents and for me in terms of
housing it's an absolute no-brainer i
just wanted to turn quickly to customer
services which is something i'm equally
passionate about
we are really really good at letting
people through the physical front door
here
um to say i haven't been happy about
worried not having its doors open is an
understatement sledgehammers have been
threatened
i haven't done it
they haven't opened their doors for
various reasons which i've found
really difficult to deal with because i
don't think that has helped their
residents at all
suffice to say that customer services uh
is in very very safe hands with the
officers who run it
and they are making progress with that
with my absolute 100 support not
necessarily with a sledgehammer
what this is really about
is giving us the resilience
to survive
we're small
i take the point that over the years we
haven't been ambitious and that there
have been
we have rested on some very insufficient
laurels when there has been there is so
much that we can do but by doing that
together with warwick
it gives us the resilience and the clout
to be taken more seriously even than we
are already at regional level with the
lep and the west midlands combined
authority
this isn't going to be comfortable
there'll be fights there'll be things we
disagree with
but by heading towards
a political merger we will avoid
the hiccups and worse
that we've had over the years of trying
to do
just shared services with other councils
they have all
ended
in having to unpick those services
which has been expensive in itself and
complicated and painful
and the main point of the of heading
towards i hope political merger
is that that won't happen that the
disagreements will be had behind closed
doors and then we will go forward as one
political entity so i absolutely support
this and i urge
however many
little problems there are and however
many things we've still got to overcome
that you will all support it
and go forward together
ask the questions
be difficult
but we'll do it
thank you
thank you councillor
sorry about that yeah obviously
um
yeah it's certainly um cancer and i've
been making some notes with my pencil
during this uh during the meeting but
i'm not sure whether it's the 2b or not
to be said
right um
i know mentioned that the herald
it's been mentioned a few times um if
you mentioned the herald in south i
would say that is it some person who
walks wrong in front of somebody quite
important saying no oh look at his uh
lord kendall or
odd lord richard's just walking in front
so i thought i picked on them
um
so yeah so
again it just shows that
in our bathroom district we we have a
different reading material
um
many of my residents as catch the parry
is obviously been reading my notes uh
certainly levitate more towards limited
spa and warwick shires
rather than coming out to stratford both
in terms of work shopping and leisure so
certainly see some benefits and it would
potentially be easier to go
to
reception et cetera one-stop shops in in
the lemton area
um and osc it was mentioned that satan
would be although could be an ideal
location for the new council
um
but i can't remember you mentioned that
but i thought i'll certainly support
that idea
um
so i think there's there's definitely
potential brand there um and
cancer promise did mention that we did
have a surgery um about this in a local
pub
and again cancer shouldn't and turned up
for shakespeare shakespeare but he
wasn't allowed in because he was barred
so that's the last one i promised
um
yeah someone's like this is my i think
things around the survey could be could
have been done better and again i think
that's something we need to learn from
and the other thing it was interesting
to note
at the osc last week that the biggest
risk highlighted at osc was officer
capacity i think it came four or four so
it was 16 on the risk register
and asked i mentioned that before and
again we do need to be mindful of that
cancer junior touched on about
working with warwick district
i actually worked for work district for
31 years straight from school before you
said that now um and and i certainly
know what what like what they do there
and i think it is about resilience you
know savings are one of the things about
residents and that became patently clear
during the pandemic
that we needed to be bigger to meet our
needs of our residents
and we supported one another the
districts and warriors on the county and
uh and that's the way we helped to get
help to our residents
um
somebody mentioned the knowledge pool uh
yeah that is true the knowledge pool is
quite important i've got visions of gene
pools as well but but but we won't get
um but particularly around housing
that is really important and again
taking care of this point i was
listening susan honest um the bit about
affordable housing i think that's quite
vital um certainly when dealing with a
certain rsl it certainly sends my blood
pressure into orbit shall we say so
again it's
it's it's not great
and whilst i don't believe the situation
we've got here is perfect i think things
could have been um done differently uh i
will be supporting maybe with a slightly
heavy heart but yeah only slightly that
i will be supporting this uh
proposal
thank you councillor building
thank you chad
um
going on to
quote shakespeare once more into the
reach dear friends
and to quote a well-known saying you can
take a horse to water but you can't make
it drink which i think mr councillor
kettle will know about
um we've i raised the matter regularly
at all my parish council meetings
they were put into the
magazines and other matters
it was
one i did what i could to get
responses from people within my ward
i know we're right on the east of the
county
but at the end of the day
it's up to the people who elected us
we are elected to lead and to make these
sort of hard decisions
and
i am
having to to make the decision
on behalf of my ward and i will go along
with the recommendations and i will
support it
thank you councillor jenny fragile
thank you
um
i've been listening very carefully and i
just got some thoughts which i just like
to put put forward i mean change is
always resented it's always
uncomfortable whatever change is going
to happen it's going to be difficult
whether we stay the same or whether we
change
some of the biggest changes are coming
our way are actually from the government
and the democratic deficit sits there
because they're looking to reduce the
numbers of councillors and perhaps the
move that we're looking at at the moment
might give some traction to question
that because i would i would find a
reduction in the number of counsellors
actually unacceptable
the amount of work that we do and the
amount of time that we have to spend
with our residents
if that goes up considerably is actually
going to produce
less uh less good service for them
um i've always seen the rationale in
shared services and it's indeed it's
something i've always supported ever
since i have i became a counselor
um
and my inclination at the moment is to
support this
but i am painfully aware that a
political merger is going to bring many
many many problems some of the thing
that some we think we know now but there
are going to be so many that are going
to come out of the woodwork which are
going to be upsetting for us and
actually upsetting for
our residents so we've got to be
incredibly resilient if we do go ahead
with this
to actually make sure
that what we do
benefits the residents and not the
counselors or a larger council
um
um
yeah
right we've got we've got coming on from
that we've got to work together we are a
collection of individuals with radically
different views or a collection of
political parties with radically
different different principles
i don't think we've always been able to
work together
in proper harmony listening to each
other's issues and listening to each
other's um
points of view and actually coming up
with compromises
i've never haven't felt that and
particularly i haven't felt that
recently so i think if we do go ahead
with this
we have really got to
listen to what we've got to say on
behalf of our residents and whatever the
decisions are made over the next two or
three years
they've got to be made together and
they've got to be made for our residents
not for political interests
um
what my final thing is i'm really
worried
that if this does happen
it's going to come as a bombshell to
residence
so many residents don't have a clue
what we've done as consultation might be
legally the legal requirement
but when it comes to residents sitting
around over christmas or whenever it
actually comes through into
consciousness that this decision has
been made on their behalf
they're going to be so many questions
then and i know from stratford stratford
has always wanted to reinvent the
borough it's always loved the borough it
resented the district it always resented
the district
and actually taking it forward into a
larger district is going to be really
quite a challenge and quite an ask as to
how that happens
so
that leaves me
rather like uh councillor crump
slightly still on the fence but
i do see the positives of it
but i've got to have absolute assurance
from everybody here that would flip and
well going to work together if we decide
this to make it work
and i do think the committee system is
one of the things that we really have to
look at because that is far more
democratic than a cabinet that actually
is seen to be top down by some of its
own party as well as those of other
parties so
thank you
great thank you councillor pemberton
the ball thank uh councillor bromage for
making my quote redundant
so we can start
when we all decided to stand for elected
office we did so because we wanted to
make a difference to our communities
for most of us we managed to affect
change in individual people's lives and
there we really do make a difference
there are times if we are lucky where we
can support our village our town our
parish and leave a positive mark
but it's only once in a lifetime that
any of us
can make a real and lasting difference
to the entire district and every single
resident
today is that day
there have been many
well thought through and impassioned
contributions all focused on our
residents needs and some genuine and
real concerns have been articulated
so i'm going to try and offer an
alternative positive vision not based on
finance and efficiencies
but how we can make our residents lives
better
organizations really transform
themselves
on the kind of scale that we are looking
to achieve
merging officers into a single
unit will create significant but at the
end incremental change
without political merger it will always
be beholden to the changes wrought by
members of both councils
only political merger can create the
opportunity for real fundamental
transformational change that will
benefit our residents
it will not be one officer if we don't
have political merger group with two
heads it'll be very many heads across
two authorities
this is the opportunity for every single
member to truly shape an entirely new
council
built on the best of warwick district
council and the best of stratfor
district council as our starting point
particularly in the areas of climate
change and affordable housing there are
huge opportunities
and once again i say this gives every
single member the opportunity to shape
the future of services for the benefits
of all of our residents across stratford
and warwick districts
we can create an entirely new and
positive future for services because
although the new cancer will face many
near-term
financial challenges
in the long term we can look to how we
can be truly innovative in delivering
services that meet our residents future
needs not just those of today
it is our opportunity as every single
member and i keep repeating that every
single member to be part of this process
to be community leaders to work through
and shape the detail of how a new south
warwickshire district council will work
this will ensure that all of our fears
and concerns and those of our residents
are addressed and allowed
the opportunity today is to shape our
future to shape a new council to shape a
new south warwickshire
to shape new lives for our residents
i urge you all to join me
roll your sleeves up and shape our new
future
because we do this not because it is
easy but because it is hard and because
it is right
thank you
thank you councillor uh councillor rock
thank you chairman i'm not quite sure i
can deal with this rhetoric it's um
i feel a hard act to follow from some of
the impassioned speeches that have been
made but uh i just wanted to pick up a
few points that have been made i haven't
got prepared speech i've been listening
to what's been said and um
just a couple of things um i i'll start
with councillor parry i absolutely
agreed about the east of the district
because i'm biased and i'm sitting next
to jason project i've got the furthest
ward in the biggest board he's got the
closest and the smallest
um
what i would be cautious about
i've heard the
no-brainer a couple of times
actually i don't want anybody to be
misled by that i think i've been quite a
hard decision for me this i've thought
about it a lot and i've done quite a bit
of analysis on it so just taken to turn
to the analysis to start with earlier on
we heard a lot about council tax
harmonization
now those of us that live in parishes
and we all do
uh
many of the services that parishes
provided street lights refuse uh tidying
up the litter and all that sort of thing
there's a bit of a blurred edge between
what the district provides and what the
parishes provide if you add up the
parish precept with the district precept
and you do the same in warwick and you
do in stratford
that difference that we've talked about
the 27-28 quid
is the opposite way
the average
difference is four pounds 28
it's cheaper to live in warwick district
at the moment than it is in stratford
district
if you look at the towns warwick
lemington kennel of stratford if you
look at those towns the difference is
nine pounds 28 cheaper to live in
warwick district towns than it is in
stratfor
so the
and that i suspect is something to do
with how that balance works between the
the district and those parishes
i want to talk about the parishes
particularly and i think there's a huge
opportunity there i think there's
something that perhaps is
counterintuitive about what we can do
because i think there's more chance to
empower parachutes
your mic's not actually working if we
can get you a new mic
has it come back on now have i got a
flat battery
no i think possibly it's made with the
flat battery but um
now of course i've lost my thread but i
think that the thing is that
in those survey comments people
gratifyingly seem to be interested in
their district councillors which comes
as a surprise to all of us i'm sure
um but they they value that connection
with the district and i think there's an
opportunity to amplify that
um
now
down to the wally hogan's made a very
impassioned street speech i very much
was interested in what she had to say
and she did mention about subsidy but of
course if we did go into a unitary
across the county there's more of a
subsidy with the north of the district
and more difference with the district so
i respectfully would disagree with her
about those sort of points and also i
i'll sit on the the negotiating
committee the jcng
and meet regularly with the employees
representative now i know they're the
union side but i can't believe their
views is very different to the rest of
the
uh that the staff on that point
and and i was struck by the level of
agreement there is between the
management and the the employee
representative so i'm not seeing that
fearful uh element that to council
william
mentions but of course that's only a
cross-section
so
by and large i've come to a position
that i would support this motion
of course
uh the east of the district
um
as uh as has been said by those from the
far east that are here uh we are
geographically closer but i think it
goes broader than that not many people
have engaged on this matter that's true
but does that mean they're against it
does it mean they understand
318 pages that we've been given to read
i suspect not we're here to make those
decisions and i think we need to
understand them so thank you very much i
i would say i'm going to support this
and i would encourage the members to do
so thank you very much chairman
thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman
we have many challenges
we should grasp them eagerly
and ensure that the south warwickshire
district council if it moves ahead
leads the way within the west midlands
i would uh
propose
that the
question is now put
thank you councillor
well i'm certainly not going to be
making any uh
impassioned speeches and shouting
a little bit offensive that certain
people are telling me
that it's a no-brainer
because i do have a brain
and i like to think about these things
and i like to listen to what people are
saying
um
i'm i'm not convinced about the rhetoric
from certain members of the ruling party
here that say we've all got to work
together it's all going to be wonderful
we're going to be part of the shaping
this future
because you know as well as i do when
push comes to shelf and it all goes
through
you're going to be the ones making the
decision and making the ultimate
decision
and you're going to be voting against
everything that we suggest and that's
the sad reality
and that
you know i [ __ ] that's why i find what
you're saying quite offensive that
you're insisting
that we
vote it's a no-brainer but at the end of
the day you're going to be the ruling
party and you're going to have to say
and so i do find that very offensive
and i find it very very difficult
because
um unless there is an element of trust
between the two of us
and i've not rehearsed this at all
because i'm getting
really quite angry when i'm listening to
some people speak and shout
um i
unless there's an element of trust
it's not going to work for me
um
when i listen to counselor wally hoggins
uh speech um
i know that she is very much in favor of
a of a whole unitary um i i find that um
very difficult to swallow it's something
that i could never ever
agree to because
i get elected um
because i represent the person next
orbit one and round the corner i don't
get elected to
represent a huge vastly huge area which
will happen if it's a whole unitary
and for me it takes away localism which
is why i also find it god i didn't think
i was going to speak this much anyway
well i was only going to make two points
which is why i also find it quite
difficult this this merger
because our ward sizes i mean it made me
slightly laugh um councillor bromish
because my ward is already the biggest
ward per population in the district and
i already have nearly four thousand so
another few hundred doesn't make any
difference the new boundary commission
if we stay at stratfor district council
gives me 2 600. yes can't wait for that
one anyway
um
i i i
it's going to be big it's going to be
big for a lot of you in terms of of
numbers and it's going to be much harder
to be local and and you know have that
local um
connection with people so i'm finding
this whole thing frankly quite difficult
um i don't i genuinely came here
uh
against the proposal
i walked into this room today
against this
merger i'm not entirely convinced anyone
has convinced me to say otherwise
and and that's why i find
certain people have kind of are trying
to say you've got to no i haven't got to
haven't got to at all
um
but then on the other hand frankly what
difference does it make if i vote
against it
because
i know what's going to happen that the
conservative party will all
vote unanimously for it well apart from
one apart from one i know
so you know frankly is it going to make
any difference
can somebody tell me if it makes any
difference if i vote for it
is it going to make any difference are
you going
are you going to listen to me
as a liberal democrat if i come up
with a reasonably good idea
no no
counselor barca because what will happen
is
you don't like suggestions from the
opposition
no one likes suggestions from the
opposition
that's what we're there for and you will
vote it down
so unless i have assurances that you are
going that we truly are
going to work together i'm not convinced
i can vote for this thank you
thank you uh councillor richards
thank you chairman
i must admit when i came here tonight in
the lead up to tonight's meeting i've
been touring and throwing between each
side of the debate i've listened
intently to what everyone has had to say
and i have you'll be pleased to know i
have come to a conclusion um
looking at listening to some of the bits
and pieces that have been said on the
one side we heard about the minutiae and
the details and that's that sort of
thing and that it lacking in this
proposal we're here to make strategic
decisions and whilst manushya and detail
is important we're here to make
strategic decisions and you don't make
strategic decisions by going through the
minutiae so we need to make that clear
we need to understand that it's a
strategy decision we're making
i'm gonna focus on the finances i'm
afraid um
strategically as a business
if the balance the books don't balance
there are two ways in which to address
that it's either make savings or charge
more for your services the only way this
council can do that because we are
limited in what we can do in order to
create income is to charge more in
council tax
or charge more in discretionary services
or indeed start charging for
discretionary services the alternative
is to get rid of them
if we're charging more the council
taxpayers the person that's paying for
it for the same level of service they're
getting
is that in itself in the best interests
of those individual taxpayers of our
residents no by merging the two councils
we have a great opportunity to make huge
savings for a number of years to come it
also gives us an opportunity to look at
the different ways in which that new
council can reset and work out ways in
which it can generate a new level of
income different levels of income for me
that makes absolute sense
so
i will be voting for this today on that
basis and i'm going to second councillor
dixon's proposal that we move now to a
vote and draw a closer tonight's meeting
thank you we'll just um counselor
jefferson do you want to have any
closing remarks
uh
thank you chair
it's been a very interesting debate
there have been an awful lot of very
good points made
i have to say i agree with quite a lot
of what counselor rock said
that the local council employees
certainly the union
are in favor
there's a survey in the document that
actually says
of 95 local council employees 55 percent
agreed
that is actually a reasonable sample
so the reality actually is
and it's the local council employees it
would really understand exactly what
this means and how it directly affects
them
the consultation exercise that was done
was done by professionals and followed
best practice
and it is just worth
saying what is on seven page seven
the survey findings are accurate enough
for reliable conclusions to be drawn
about residents opinions on the
council's proposals
there's an awful lot being said about
democratic representation
and this i think members of council is
where we are going to have to work hard
make no bones about that when it comes
to how efficient and how effective
councils are
that is largely down to the council's
really driving the council to be
efficient and effective it's not about
councillors standing back
and not taking an active interest
there will have to be broad involvement
in terms of making this submission to
the department for leveling up
housing and communities and i would just
comment that the deputy leader and i
meet fortnightly with the leader and
deputy leader of the liberal democrats
so we are already
in dialogue
we can't have all the details about the
merger at this point i've been through
mergers
the details emergency really start to
slog through it and i'm sorry but that's
actually the reality
someone said and i think it was
councillor bromage it's going to be hard
you bet your life it's going to be hard
it is not going to be easy it is going
to be a long slog
do the positives outweigh the negatives
in my view yes
the two key points that have been made
about the housing revenue account and
what that can do for housing i think are
extremely valuable
i think the point made about resilience
is absolutely critical
if we stay separate
we will be forced to keep on making
cuts year after year and lose resilience
people talk about being bold ambitious
and innovative
i kind of think this proposal is really
quite bold and ambitious
so
i think we now have an opportunity
as councillors
to shape the future
so i urge everyone
to vote for the recommendations to
council on page one of the cabinet's
notice of extraordinary meeting
recommendations four five six and seven
oh and eight sorry i forgot to turn over
the page
thank you chair great thank you and
thank you everyone for your comments it
was really quite interesting so um
moving forward we've got a proposal and
a second uh are we in agreement
council chick is it possible to have a
recorded vote
just looking for a proposal a seconder
for that councillor pemberton thank you
so much we've all now moved to a
recorded vote and i invite david
brooklyn to carry that out
thank you chairman thank you council for
the debate this evening i just want to
be absolutely clear before we we take
the vote we have item 15 on the
supplementary papers that was of
circulated this evening council
jefferson referred to recommendation for
that was recommendation for on the
cabinet agenda
the recommendations you have to consider
tonight are recommendations one to five
on pages three and four of the
supplementary paper the first
recommendation being amended to the
point that
it is recommended that the council make
a formal submission
to to department level up
i am so sorry council i've taken that
off several times tonight and i
apologize i should have taken off for
the most crucial vote in the last 47
years of the council's history so if i
can start
again be absolutely clear we have got
supplement item 15 on the paper that was
circulated this evening
seeking for a on block vote i'm looking
at chairman on the five recommendations
that are put to you tonight the first
recommendation being
that
a submission is made to the department
11 up housing the communities to create
a southwester council
i will be calling your name in turn and
i would ask whether you please state
that you're voting for
against
or abstaining to those five
recommendations
is there any questions before i go to
the vote
because wally hoggins
so are we
are we going through this
one to five with a recorded vote for
each one is that what we've just agreed
to or is this just
thank you
thank you
okay
so
councillor bitter
council of fitter for
thank you councillor dixon councillor
dixon ball
thank you councillor barker
councillor barker iv
thank you councillor brummidge
councillor brotherage again
thank you councillor cleve
councillor cleve abstain
thank you councillor crump
councillor crumpfort
thank you councillor curtis councillor
curtis four
thank you councillor eden
councillor eden for
thank you councillor fielding
thank you councillor fleming
thank you counselor ian frenchly
thank you councillor jenny frenchly
thank you um councillor harvey
council harvey four
thank you councillor john jefferson
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings four
councillor junit
councillor june 84
thank you can i please remind
councillors to turn our counselors on
mike's on when they're they're they're
coming back um councillor kendall
councillor kendall four
thank you councillor kettle councillor
kettle for
thank you councillor mills
council mules for thank you
um councillor o'donnell
council o'donnell four
thank you councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you
councillor pemberton
councillor pemberton four
thank you councillor peter keller
councillor cortez iv
thank you councillor richards
councillor richards iv
thank you councillor riley
councillor riley four
thank you councillor rock
councillor rock four thank you uh
councillor wolf
council ralph abstain
thank you now councillor shenton
councillor shenton four
thank you and councillor wally hoggins
councillor wally hoggins against thank
you
chairman i make that 26 votes four three
against with two abstentions
so thank you everyone for that passes um
and now i'll close the meeting but i
want to wish you all very merry
christmas and happy new year
can i just uh make a comment mr chairman
uh mr chairman for wearing such a lovely
jumper today
obviously must have been for a bet so i
would like to hope to think tonight that
fellow councils may well give you a
little donation to your mayoral charity
for entertaining us with such a
fantastic garment thank you councillors
great suggestion thank you
and i'll even put my money in my pocket
straight away for you
it's not going to come out